did you plank uh I still don't know what
that means I thought that was a sex
thing it's like Prince William likes
getting planked I thought that was a
phrase this also reminds me what he
didn't realize oh this was bad I thought
harambe died of natural
causes I don't
understand uh welcome to another episode
of trash taste uh I'm Jord once again by
the boys Jer and gone and a returning
guest fili your face Pete it's Peter hey
guys nice thanks for having me back I
appreciate
you wearing the same thing you were last
time slightly different new scarf and a
new sweater the same color
combinations consisteny
G that way you like that one one clip
that you're like you only need like five
suits in your life yeah I'm definitely
that guy I feel like if I consistently
wear similar things it'll look like one
big great episode over all the days so
yeah I mean you will voted for episode
of the year at the
TR very humbling I concerned that I got
the the biggest gigachad I had to look
up what that meant and then well I think
it was cuz you told the kid to to kill
themselves I did not say to kill
themselves I
assisted with a dodgeball but it's very
different but like yeah Giga Chad is
something that if you knew me growing up
uh from ages 1 to 35 you would never
apply that term to describe me but I I
take it I'll take those W's it's pretty
cool yeah yeah how you been uh since
last time it's been how many months now
since been 10 I think yeah it's been
good I've um I've done so many things
since retiring from teaching which was
kind of the point of the last episode
congratulations congrats Cong traveled
the world and saw Paris twice I'm so
sorry yeah oh I'm I'm not sorry anymore
we notorious France haters on this
podcast sorry FR well the parisians have
a friend in me because I thought it was
excellent but I will say my favorite
parts of being in Paris was eating
outside or having you know a beer um
like overlooking and watching people and
everyone says that's just a worse
Italy and I said okay well I haven't
Italy they're not wrong well I thought
it was cool and I like should like a
very European thing eat Out outdoors in
Sumer especially and I think twitchcon
is normally EU is in Sumer right uh yes
it was very very common yeah I loved
Paris I like how they have the
uniformity of the building codes it
makes for a nice night walk and the the
lighting at night in Paris is undefeated
is this your first time in Europe yes
and I haven't visited anywhere else you
to went went to the UK which is on the
continent of Europe yeah but you guys
didn't want to be a part of it so it's
like hey don't don't blame me I'm just
saying I Mainland Europe I've only been
to one place so Mainland Europe mland
still in Europe I mean the
greater yeah but I mean it was it was
fun you ate good food prbly you I'm
almost jealous you had a good time in
Paris it was great both times so you
went twice once was for recreation just
for you know just just on my own the
second was for twitchcon okay and uh but
yeah this past year has been a whole
different world of getting to
collaborate with others and do
Adventures that were otherwise
unavailable to me due to a teaching
schedule so I've been a lucky guy this
past year yeah man yeah it's been great
good stuff it seems like you've
definitely kind of like do like move
straight head first into quitting
teaching and the creat life and going
into like the Creator life we're so
sorry that's uh what a mistake one of us
now yeah my my mother was so proud of me
and uh now she's like you talk on camera
I'm like yeah Mom it's amazing she's
like I don't like watching it I all
right so your mom doesn't say that no
she can't figure out what twitch is yet
I've sent to the my parents I've sent it
to them like five times I think it took
like maybe the 10th of chemp for them to
finally like actually click it and
figure out what twitch was well it was
different from YouTube it's very
different and my mom's she's 73 God
bless her and she chose the name gypsy
girl
5057 and uh and so now people when she's
typing I can see Chatters being like
what's up Gypsy I was like don't talk to
my mom like that she's not a gypsy girl
she's not why did she choose Gypsy I
don't know she's just really in tune
with like that kind of whole traveling
and kind of I don't know what that's
what she chose and uh but she she could
have just chosen well she's got to she's
got to change her username now that you
just said that on camera well she's not
there enough so it's okay she's not
she's not there enough when she next
time though you're streaming and she's
in the chat everyone's going to be like
hey I'd rather it be out that now no one
can hit on her or talk to her
differently so let leave her alone D yes
I was most certainly going to hit on
gypsy
girl you have to sorry yeah it's cool to
for my family to not understand what I'm
doing it's kind of awesome so I don't
know it's kind of nice though when
they're like you do what you like like
yeah it's kind of weird but it's fun I
kind of like the almost you know you're
kind of carving your own kind of way
very satisfying for sure the only tricky
part and maybe you guys can relate to
this given some of the topics that
you've discussed on this channel to have
like close family members like your your
mom sisters or something and then they
watch a clip of you talking about some
sort of titty anime you're like well I
can I can defend this it it's weird to
talk about stuff that is kind of
immature and then have like your uncle
yeah but that this is the Assumption
Pete that you that my family has great
expectations of me which they most
certainly do not the moment I said I
want to be a YouTuber fulltime it just
went downhill they like all right like
of course he's talking about anim tities
it's whatever I feel like my parents
have gone through an entire character
Arc that they've just not told me about
of like acceptance they've gone through
like the five stages of grief and I've
just seen the acceptance part of it but
my parents just don't mention it they
just don't mention it they just don't
mention it they're like we really like
what you do 95% of the time we don't we
don't talk about the other the other 5%
that's a small way of doing just turning
the Blind Eye yeah like well come of
pays the bills does your do your parents
still say yeah my son he's a uh he's a
lifeguard do they just go to like the
last job you no no they they they like
that I do YouTube I it's something you
can I think my grandma my grandma says
that I'm a
comedian which is the biggest stretch in
the world no comedian works I get
clowned sometimes you know I'm just
doing stuff like that but yeah well
do why do you have to tell people you
don't do this Jo no no no no I I don't
think anybody asks but uh and the main
thing is I um I think that my family is
intrigued by and it helps that I'm so
far away in Japan they think it's a
phase I certainly I'm 40
G you
asse first of all I can assume and I
feel like I'm getting this as you get
older people just stop caring what
you're doing they're like you've you
have to have figured it out by now I
don't care like as long as you're not
ruining your life M character it's fine
no one is no one's the main character
character so yeah I think it's an
amusing little Quirk that I've gone
fulltime into playing video games and
and talking about you know stuff on the
internet hey man that's the dream Joel
for a while it is the dream Joel I'm
impressed cuz you you managed to even
adapt to a streamer sleep schedule many
times sometimes I'll see I'll wake up in
the morning and Pete's been on for nine
hours and I'll be like wait it's you say
you're 40y old I've seen I've seen like
your lifetimes I'm like there is no way
this man is 40 years old think even from
a young age I've always preferred the
nocturnal hours to daytime I've always
enjoyed being awake all night gamer
right here but like like you said I've
been playing games since they came since
they were invented so that hand in hand
goes with
nighttime I beta tested like rock paper
scissors it was just like rock rock and
then we were like okay to shake it
off one of these days but it's been wait
for the theory video is like how old is
Pete really well if we go back in
time but yeah it's I've always preferred
those hours anyway so this is a perfect
job for someone like me yeah did you did
you ever stuer from like insomnia or
anything like that or is it just
something where you just found more
comfort in the night time is it just
natural to you it's just natural and so
like even some of the jobs I had in
before even coming to Japan where like
the overnight shift at these places or
or The Late Late sh sh the graveyard
shifts plus you know I think like true
Gamers and true nerds will unite in
knowing that well I guess it's gotten
easier now but in the old days at school
there was no smartphones or tablets or
laptops so you all of your nerd [__] had
to be done in between the hours of like
6:00 p.m. and 3:00 a.m. before you went
to school the next day I think all of us
were kind of in the same yeah I think so
right I didn't have access I just don't
have the energy to do it now oh well I
hit 11:00 p.m. and I'm like [__] it's I
can I can easily go till 4: or 5 but you
the thing that sucks is I really really
hate this this sobering moment when
you're like I should probably get oh
it's light outside I love that I hate
that I love it all the breakfast menu is
open so oh no I guess it's just I mean
it is slightly haunting when you when
you leave your dark room and then you go
outside and it's it's 900 a.m. yeah yeah
people have already gone to
work oh my God I just like I I remember
having this sobering moment where I
think we did like all night karaoke or
something like that and you know the sun
had come out it was like the uh getting
the last train and I just like I was
just looking at everyone walking past me
and I [__] despised everyone cuz I
was like [__] these people with an
adequate amount of sleep in their body
right now that should have been me and I
think that was the last time it sounds
like an amazing idea until you actually
do it and then the next morning you're
like [__] I shouldn't have done that
just wake up at 2 p.m. then you know so
just just adjust your sleeping times
that's not what every motivational video
Under the Sun say they get up at like
3:00 a.m. last
month three hours of sleep well I guess
I'm just unorthodox in my approach to
anything I've ever done so I like it has
twitch changed much uh has live
streaming changed in any amount since
you were last on or anything significant
you've Revelations you've had or since I
started streaming or Twitch in general
oh since you started streaming
um no full time she been pretty smooth
sailing well I mean it's not smooth
sailing I guess but for me it's it's I I
hearken back to more of like the older
days of twitch which is kind of more you
know let's plays and like hanging out I
kind of try to imagine that I'm just
having a game night or a land party at
and it just so happens that everyone is
there with me and I know that twitch has
changed a lot with like doing events and
having these these kind of cool things
but for me I've had the similar approach
when it's my channel just to kind of
enjoy yeah thatu keeping it casual yeah
it's been great fun yeah I really like
it I would not change this job for
anything it's a pretty nice job just
getting to play your favorite game all
games you hate it's been some of your
favorite games that you've been able to
share with the world on stream this is
this is so bad because the games that I
want to Champion it's not the ones for
they not bu for twitch and it's it's
it's I get labeled a lot as a retro
streamer and I'm really not because I
play a lot of modern games but I think
I swear I swear not being those
allegations no but I I think of the
people who are in Japan I might be the
only one who does stream retro more
often than not so that's all I get but
games like hio Kojima snatcher Monkey
Island all the old from our from our
generation My Generation you played them
though I never played Monkey Island oh
monkey Island's great Monkey Island is a
great game too much talking really for
me you you get to voice act them though
there's no there's no voice so yeah I
one thing that I'm impressed by is that
you always are voice acting all all the
characters on The Stream which is which
is fun but also for me it's very
exhausting to voice act all the
characters oh but I you love that [__]
don't you and also I I hate voicing like
uh if there's a as a woman character my
range is just not that of such where I
could do it comfortably at all well
that's going to be a given given that we
are we have such deep voice back when I
was streaming I used to use that as an
excuse to
practice Yeah but I'm never going to
voice act a woman my my range is just
would be very brutal being like that's a
[__] voice and I'll be like all right
let's not do that and to me it's like
I'm I'm sitting there and I'm like
there's a character that I feel like is
really in in my my range and I can
really give it a really good crack and
I'm like yes this the thought of having
to end this lineage right here and then
I go to oh jeez I don't know I'm like
I'm like and I'm like oh my God this is
just like the dichotomy between me
giving a really like trying to do this
voice W and then having to be like I'm
I'm in the same canas feed I I love
doing and also typically I I whenever
I've done games or I've done uh whatever
anime I'm never the main character in
these types of my voice is generally not
main character material um so the main
character is always like yeah let's do
it and it's just like this doesn't
really work then when the villain comes
on I'm like all right let's go you get
to be you get to decide what all these
guys sound like and so that's that that
is the best part and obviously any woman
voice that I've ever done unless it's
like the the secretary that I used the
same voice for my mom where it's like
you know ghost bust is what do you want
like that's fine I can get away with
that on per game but the most
universally hated voice that I I think
sounds accurate but everybody seems to
disagree as my any child in any video
game I give the same voice and it sounds
like this you guys can be the official
okay let's it's not that
impressive closing my eyes I'm closing
my eyes imagine I'm like six okay okay
okay that's [__] awful that's how
kids talk I've never met a kid
where in the [__]
Sopranos you sound like Marling
water that kid voice did that Ki just
like pack away like a pack of
malur 100% Canon so it's like the
average Kansas City
kid papers smoken s all right well I
guess that's a loss but um I I'm not
changing or budging from that voice I
mean it's funny when you did it but
imagining a whole stream of you doing
that I can imagine could get a big
grading that's why I lost so many
followers no but uh but yeah other than
voice acting and and twitch things um
you never know how long these careers
are going to last because they're so
finite of course and so I just I just
hope that as I have with all the weird
careers and jobs that I've had I hope
this one leads to something satisfying
as well by its natural conclusion yeah
this this is completely off topic I
don't think I've ever asked you this
were you a theater kid in in school yes
I bro he is the ultimate I I was just I
was just like I just wanted to confirm
because I just assumed you were I
figured that out first five minutes of
meeting okay I was also a a theater
major in college so I doubled down into
debt um but so I think as long as I can
remember performance or theater but
theater kid seems to be more of an
insult these days I've noticed it's like
kind of I think it just means more
expressive it depends on the person I
think it's the energy you know it's the
energy of just not not exactly like
wanting to be the center of attention
but just wanting to go out there and
express themselves maybe that's true
yeah but it's it was ain't nothing wrong
with that a nothing wrong that but I I
noticed these days it's just a unique
energy you know I think it's like people
who are like willing to throw themselves
into a moment for like for like whatever
a purpose like in joke with your friends
or if it's a performance or whatever is
a kid considered an insult I think now I
think now it depends on the like let's
go back to 25 years ago right when I was
around high school and stuff you had
jocks you had band kids you had choir
kids you had like choir kids yeah like
the ones who sing a lot you know those
nerds but like you know no I'm kid I'm
kidding I was in choir but they kicked
me out but like but theater kid wasn't
really an established trophy okay
actually before you before you get
further I just everything you just named
out sounds like a typical American High
School movie I wanted to I I want to ask
how accurate are American High School
movies cuz I remember like when I first
started dating Sydney I was like oh was
your school like this was the Dynamics
like this and and her school was like no
it was like nothing like that was your
scho I think it so before I answer the
question I am very curious on to see
what is your imagination can you tell me
what is your expectation of an American
High School getting pushed into the
lockers lockers yeah getting p in
lockers uh the jocks uh basically every
mid 2000s American High School Lea
jacket Lea jackets jocks are always
dating one of the cheerleaders there's
the girl that's not like other girls
that everyone secretly crushes over
everyone drives to school oh everyone
drives to school everyone bullies all
the AV club kids oh certainly I was
Captain of that but that's and debate so
I was like I was really I was I was down
basically if you distilled mean girls
into reality that's like what I imagined
it would be I would say from when I went
to high school Embrace yourselves from
98 to 2002 there was a very strong
semblance of these kind of broad Strokes
of personalities it was very clicky is
really what it was so jocks or or sports
related people didn't usually cross over
into theater kids were they the cool
kids I would say that to put it into
context um somehow I won prom King my
senior year this was an unprecedented
feat in this sense before me the
previous 19 winners had been Sports
captains right and so I think you broke
the meta man I broke the meta by Thug
intimidation and like rigging the votes
but like no but like for a really long
time your your Val victorians or your
your most popular kid
would be sports or the captain of the
basketball football wrestling team sh
out to me when I was watching American
school stuff and I guess even when I see
pictures of it now I'm like huh we have
like way less stuff in British schools
we just don't have a lot of things
seemed like the facilities were really
good in American schools like they like
the idea of having lockers I was like
that's you guys didn't have lockers no
you don't get a locker I thought
everything was like poter you had common
rooms no you don't get lockers you get
lockers in your school right I don't
think we did no we didn't have lockers
we had lockers but they weren't like the
huge American siiz ones crazy you get a
locker like that's why you would low up
BR a bag and you just lug it around all
day no no no we because the most
valuable time was the like 5 to 10
minutes between class we' go to your
locker and hang out and like you'd have
like the full Suite of whatever you know
we didn't really get time in between
classes you usually just go right to the
next one what goes in a locker well you
got your bags that's most
important
girls had like mirrors and makeup and
like all kinds of different things that
they could you know address and stuff uh
I kept comic books Game Boy materials uh
you know trading cards you know things
that were more relevant to someone my
age in the90s and then I guess nowaday I
can just I I I'm like imagining just
your character archetype in every like
high school movie now yeah I was the kid
pushed into the locker and I'd be like
I'm G to get you I I also saw this new
School in Texas it was like I don't know
if you can get a picture of it there was
this like super school being built in
Texas okay and the cafeteria was just
all fast food
chains the thought of having a fast food
chain in the school blows my mind uh I
don't know if I could oh it's like a
yeah fast food CH there was like this
yeah look at this yeah yeah CLI that one
click that one wa that's a mle this is
this is a high school high school in
Texas it has Sonic uh Jimmy
John isn't this insane not even how uni
had this I think I think genuinely if
this happened in the UK there'd be a
riot why you the thought of allowing
these Brands into your school yeah to
like get kids like hooked on this style
of
food I had this feeling when uh I think
we had a brief conversation about this
on an RV trip but I remember thinking
like those you only go to those
McDonald's parties as a kid I feel like
man I think McDonald's did such a good
job on influencing me to like McDonald's
my entire life absolutely oh you're
talking about the playen era yeah like
you'd have everyone would have
McDonald's parties and it was like a
treat when you get to go and it's like
they did such a good way of like dude
the McDonald's ice slap I feel like
there's a I have this like deep like
calling that I just like McDonald's a
lot and and I don't feel like I it's
because I was like wow this is really
tasty and I just feel like it's a thing
that I've always liked yeah and it's a
constant that I have it's always been in
like the recesses of your and I feel
like that's how you get like lifelong
customers is by putting [__] Jimmy
John's in school and then getting them
onto it yeah and making a profit
Domino's and Subway was our twos that
but there was two different food courts
there was the food court which had like
the slop that they put on the the thing
and you ordered it there was an ocart
section yeah and then like a a different
food court that had pizza and Subway
sandwiches that's crazy so who would
ever go to the slop section um actually
a fair amount of people because
expensive right to it's about the same
right cuz you get the pizza by the slice
or you get like a $5 sub way sandwich
but the interesting thing about the food
court is you ended up over four years of
high school getting your favorite like
oh man the mozzarella sticks are great
also I like the cheeseburgers over here
because they taste this way sounds so
unhealthy already I mean it's American
school system what do you expect it's
how we do things but yeah I'm I'm trying
to think of like when I started to like
stuff like you know McDonald's Pizza
Huts and things like that and I'm like
would I have liked it if I didn't have
it as a kid and I think I still would I
don't know I I'm sure there's some
things I would still like but I feel
like it's definitely solidified my my
love for this because McDonald's has
that taste y it's a very distinct taste
and I feel like I've been hooked on that
since I was a kid it's weird that we
have cravings for McDonald's yeah yeah I
get cravings for McDonald's that's
unhealthy yeah bro I'm loving it I'm
loving it there you go so I mean yeah I
do feel like it's hacked some part of my
brain well it used to be a reward like
you didn't nowadays eat fast food all
the time but I remember when we grew up
it was kind of like once every two or
three weeks or after like a dentist
you'd go get a milkshake or something
but now it's uh a lot of people just eat
it every day oh I have a lot of
people admission yeah pretty bad I don't
I think it was like the fries that
hooked me on McDonald's fries are good
like there's something on the menu that
I think everyone has a craving for I in
about the fries where you know no matter
what McDonald's fries will always be a
staple no matter where I go in the world
something that I will crave um it's the
Big Mac for me and it's not the Big Mac
I like the the spicy chicken one spicy
chicken spicy chicken that one is also
good so good in in Japan you got to get
it they try to double it down the spicy
beef and I'm like it ain't the same no
no it's not very good damn I'm glad you
yeah we we we shared a mutual love of
the spicy chicken I don't think we've
ever SED for a [__] FAL food chain as
much as we have now now we're like in
high school again if I'm sure if I had
[__] Jimmy John's at school I'd be
like go is good but I shouldn't get
hooked on it as a kid yeah I should I
should be forced to eat [__] like
broccoli but okay if were you forced to
eat [__] like broccoli yes yes surely
that should have conditioned you to like
it though right but no actually like
some of wait no yes I like broccoli love
broccoli you love broccoli I think
because I was forced to eat it and get
familiar with it As I Grew Older I then
became slowly over time you're like oh I
kind of like this thing now and I feel
like that's how a lot of why I can't
enjoy a lot of Japanese Foods because I
wasn't forced to eat them growing up
like Nat is kind of tough for me cuz I
never had anything like that smell or
Texture I feel like there is an element
of that to it uh but I also feel like I
don't know maybe children just have
different palettes as well of course
they do but change they there are so
many things that I hated as a kid and
you know um I kind of every time I ate
it like no matter how much my parents
tried to force me I would be like no I
don't want to [__] eat this you know
and then I swear if you eat something
though a lot growing up you will
gradually become more used to it unless
you're really like traumatized or
scarred by like
tequila well alol that does yeah I mean
I I got like no one should be ingesting
that I got traumatized out of ever
eating [__] brussel sprouts for like
so many years uh and now I [__] love
them and you know had a period of my
life same with uh cauliflower I I like I
I ate a lot of cauliflower as a kid and
uh that like meant that when I was a
young adult I was just like I can choose
not to eat cauliflower anymore and now I
think it tastes [__] great yeah
I don't know maybe it's a thing as well
maybe maybe I don't
know there a lot of kids who like grow
up not eating like certain things and
that just like persists for the rest of
their life and there's no explanation to
it yeah it's wild I think it's just it's
a mindset yeah and I think it is a
mindset maybe also I think I went too
far like when we're young your parents
say you know when you're older you can
eat cookies in bed all right and then
when I got older I did
endlessly and then I got don't mind if I
story a right there I overindulged on
the freedom and then it kind of went
past the Tipping Point back around where
I'm like I like eggplant and and spinach
and CIF I feel like you you have to
overindulge though at some point in your
life so that you're like man I I I know
how it feels to overindulge and I'll go
back cuz when you're a kid when you
overindulge you don't you're like this
is the best thing ever yeah but as like
a young adult you know you have a a
night where you're just eating like
three packets of chips and and a Diet
the next morning you're just like oh God
I shouldn't have done that you just
described last night for me but thank
you very much I appreciate it yes but
yeah that's right part of the charm was
being told you couldn't do that so
you're like but now it just makes me
want to but what if I want ice cream for
breakfast that sounds incredible and
then you do it once you do it and you're
like oh this is bad is disgusting I'm
shoting myself at 10 in the
morning what's your go-to comfort food
in Japan I think I've ever asked you
this man go-to comfort food you're
you're not concern about calories you
just want something that's kind of quick
but it's what is what's the go-to
comfort food for you I mean it's it's
tough right there's actually there's a
two part answer one is if I'm craving
something Western because I miss that
aspect of my life it'll probably be
Mexican food I just love Mexican food
and um if it's the Japanese side it's
Ramen Ramen and these are such
unoriginal answers I know but it Mak
these are just great comfort foods and
like a tonko Ramen like with spinach and
like it it's good at really anytime
after 2 p.m. until 4 a.m. I would eat
that any anytime and then Mexican food
is just goated oh yeah we always go
Mexican food places it's it's so weird
because Mexican food was never really
part of our palet growing up in the UK
it was so hard to find a Mexican food
restaurant uh and now you know it's it's
weird growing up and now I have cravings
about Cuisines for Cuisines that I never
had growing oh my mom used to always
make those uh Old El Paso starter kids
yeah those are great
hard shell ones shell there also shoft
ones too those are goed though I I still
have cravings for this because dud I
still I still remember the ads and I my
mom used to make the fajita one all the
time and I used think they taste so
myang these are great these are still
goated
all Mexican style remember the you can
like throw in just a bunch of chicken
and a bunch of peppers you're like man I
feel kind of good about this like I
don't feel awful I mean I still
sometimes do like breakfast burritos in
the morning absolutely yeah with like
some chicken and spinach and stuff like
it's it's goated but when whenever I go
to uh whenever I go to California I'm
just REM minded how godamn good Mexican
food that it's really that breakfast
burrito we had that was amazing cuz I
feel like a lot of breakfast burritos my
problem is is that a lot of the time uh
all the ingredients don't really blend
well sometimes the egg is too scrambled
or the bacon is too overpowering and so
it's really easy to get a breakfast
bagel it's just like kind of like egg
and bread and sorry breakfast burrito
I'm sorry but in California man oh there
you go yeah they figured it out so hard
I do miss the totinos pizzas from when I
was these were like
79 little they're like they're like this
big you know they're like not the little
you're talking about pizza pizza rolls
yeah pizza rolls also totinos but the
totinos pizzas were I think that
sustained me through college is it
totinos or Tostinos I don't know it's
either totinos or toos right it's maybe
we I've never even had this by the way
but I it's uh yeah is it totinos yeah
it's toos totinos yeah to I know my to
pizza but even not the pizza rolls
themselves because those were uh
delectable snack but the the old 79 cent
pizzas have you seen this have you seen
this one what
in has one baz Clan orange chick chicken
totina pizza roll I'm never moving I did
see someone on Tik Tok make a breakfast
burrito with that and it was the saddest
like thing no took me off of totinos
completely chicken pizza s that's just
not what I'm looking for but yeah I do
miss Cravings but you know what I I
think Japan is one of the great places
on Earth that you can really go outside
your house and find 25 different things
to eat for really affordable prices
absolutely we're pretty lucky in that
regard my brother's visiting right now
and he's uh just amazed at how cheap
everything is and I'm like well mind the
Yen also the Yen keeps tanking it did
tank it came in a good time yeah I was
like you you have a very good rate right
now every week I'm like oh it's a new
record low that's that's great all my he
went to he went to ichiran and he loved
it ion's not bad CH I I love ichiran I
think it's still good I know Joey hates
it I think it's over smug Hees overated
the noodles are not it tastes great the
most five out of 10 thing ever well
still I like Ramen but I think
McDonald's of ramen it is which I it's a
comt but I'll never line up for it these
people who [__] line up for 40
minutes oh psych what the [__] psychotic
stop yeah the the big thing about
America though that surprised me cuz we
just came back from Las Vegas Los
Angeles was my God the prices of food is
insane though I went to a sandwich place
and I was feeling pretty badass I was
like don't worry guys I got it and then
uh we got five sandwiches and these were
just like normal Italian but some mom
and pop they were very good they were
they were very good but and then I I I
was like I have a card and I thumped it
down on the table like I was the king of
all creation and then it was like beep
beep and I was like what's going on over
there they're like sir it's been
declined and I was like
look at is $125 for five sandwiches
$125 $25 sand it was 20 to two 20 to $22
per sandwich and I didn't even include
the tip yet plus taxes and then of
course somebody what the [__] was in a
cavar that's what I thought it was to be
fair it was some fancy Italian one well
it was they baked their own bread was
just
something we're in La we couldn't we
listen we can go la or Las Vegas la oh
these are La prices that makes sense and
it was because you added the BR to each
sandwich which was like an extra $5
which is way way of a priz well anyway I
was like try this card please and then
they were like it's been declined I was
like here's all my money that I brought
and then you know I was embarrassed I
couldn't believe
$125 for for five sandwiches that's like
almost 20,000 yen it isn't that insane
yeah we we did have this discussion of
like how that would be a full-on
restaurant meal yeah yeah it'd be like
an Omak like a recommended Sushi course
for that kind like alcohol and a bunch
it is absurd well I think uh yeah every
everything was so expensive yeah I feel
bad for my Americans out there I
understand your pain there was now now I
know why every American just like
whenever they come to Japan it's like a
kid in a County store they're like I
could buy everything this is only $3 we
had a a night free in Los Angeles and um
we we were going to go out to
uh can I tell the
story we we go out to this uh we found
this cool gaming bar well P found it I
found it and uh it was like 20 minutes
away we like yeah [__] it let's go let's
do it we go over to this gaming
bar and uh it's like kind of a I would I
would say it's a little sketchy area it
wasn't like it was uh it was it wasn't
like the best anyway so the's security
at the door of this bar and we go in and
he's like for a Barcade I'm sorry who's
going into a barade and causing troubles
okay so you know we go in and uh we're
sitting there and we just had like a
such a long talk with this Uber driver
as well that went on for ages so I was I
felt like I was like I was like okay
let's play some games and it looks
amazing there's so many like old retro
games there's a giant list of craft
beers and food and I was like oh okay
and it's all kind of tucked behind this
glass where you can see it all you can
do anything you want for the next six or
seven hours beautiful we met with this
kind of like what I can only describe as
uh what's the what's the old guy from
Breaking Bad called again Mike Mike it's
like a mikees kind of security guard
sitting there and obious obviously we're
in LA and it's very common where they'll
ask for your ID yeah uh and you know
normally you can kind of get away with
whatever ID you have so I but I happen
to have my passport and I show it and
and Pete you show your Japanese card
he's like what is this I was like well
it's an ID from Japan that is a nation
he was like I'm going to need to see
something with letters yeah he's said he
said something with letters and I I
point out to him I'm like oh you know
this you know the date of birth is is
right there in numbers numbers are
Universal uh it's say date of birth in
English on and he was doing all the
stuff he was holding it up there's not
even a light to hold it up to he's like
in this dark piece like I never seen
nothing like with this sque and I was
like there's also letters on the top
that says nation and like date of birth
yeah it's written in English it's
written in English and he was like I'm
not going to let you in unless you have
your passport and I was like well now
you're doubting that I'm American I was
like where do you think I'm coming
from or it's it's either you about your
high school years now yeah like he's
bullying me yeah he's like I can't let
you win unless I scan it I was like scan
what like what do you mean like like not
to you know not to be mean but you don't
luck under
21 was on the 20 to 22 is when in
England it's like The Challenge 25 rule
uh there's no such thing in the UK of if
you look old they're not going to [__]
well if you look experienced mature
they're chates season 3 um but no I was
quickly humbled and there was nothing on
Earth we could do show my passport what
the [__] he denied all sorts of my other
cards and and different you know health
insurance and he was like unless it's
got letters I can't scan it and we were
like all right so we had to turn away
from this
glorious blinking shining thing and I
took you to the worst fried chicken
place and all of sports bar that looked
kind of cool and it had like a retro
sign of punch out outside it l really
cool and the lighting was awesome we we
sit down and I got the chicken tenders I
was a child would you you got a chicken
burger I did and uh they were just it
was like what $15 for this thing and it
was they were just like like frozen
nuggets it was horrible it was the worst
I I found out something by the way so I
felt so I was like don't worry Connor
I'll pay for this he was very annoyed he
was very upet down and they were like
it's been declined I was like
I no I I this one it worked and uh we
got our thing you know what I found out
all of that was vegan that's why it was
oh so it wasn't a chicken place I blame
the vegans how find because I was so
upset that I picked the worst chicken
spot on the planet you want of the
reason you want I wanted to know how
could this exist with chicken that this
bad that makes so much sense it tastes a
lot better now it was like it was like
it was a chicken tender and it came out
looking like uh like a cylinder and I
was like like what the [__] is this i b
into it yeah and I bite into it and it
was like crumbled I was like what the
[__] is this and I was in full defense
mod I was like you know a lot of
chickens they look like that it's just
the different cuts it's just an American
chicken you know it's we've seen that
before it was a square and I was like H
you know the thighs these days you know
and so they roed them up yeah but uh
kind of redemption Arc that they were
trying to give Chicken okay that makes
that makes me feel better chicken place
I like it a lot more now does it make it
better no it was still bad food I mean I
mean the fried pickles were good which
is a thing I wish that Japan would adopt
and the UK the pickles just deep fried
I'm like this is great I love just deep
fried great yeah that was a horrible
horrible um $100 we spent trying to go
to one
Barcade yeah D $100 I mean two Ubers
plus the the meal and you're looking at
like and we didn't even do
anything so it was um yeah it sounds
like La so damn how' you find Las Vegas
I hated it no I'm kidding it was Vegas
was cool I think well I think I said
this on the previous episode Vegas is
like a two-day thing I think four days
was just too long in Vegas this is 100%
the case I feel like if you're G to go
and the big thing is hey what happens in
Vegas stays in Vegas let's gamble I
think the Friday Saturday finish
Saturday night go back or Sunday morning
is but I think anything longer than
those 48 Hours you you just hate the
experience by the end but um personally
speaking I love gambling and I love the
idea of of risking it all where I'm like
you know all I'm black and they're like
you lose or I'm playing Blackjack and I
don't know the rules that well I'm like
I'll stay and they're like sir it's
eight I'm like I like to live dou and
then he like you lose but it was so much
fun for me to to be a part lose money
yeah to lose money uh with with you know
Vigor you go with style you have to go
in the mindset of I'm going to lose this
money and is well I did yeah I did lose
we did lose well the one night he he he
got very annoyed at me one night um
because we I'd been losing all night and
I was like guys One Last Hand we bet it
all and he had just won a big hand he
did he just won a big hand and I was
like guys if we're going to leave we
should just put all our [__] money on
the table and if we lose we lose and if
we win it'll be an epic story of course
we lose of course we lost immediately
immediately it was like oh the dealer
got 21 it was we didn't get to play it
we didn't even get to play it cuz Vegas
has this horrible system where the
dealer gets to basically like win
instantly in it's it's [__] don't I mean
generally gambling in Vegas is just a
terrible idea in general but unless you
play craps no craps that is a a a sport
of Kings because you control the outcome
no you don't you have you don't know how
MA Works gambling works I'm telling you
that's way more skill-based oh my God
please do not listen to this this is
absolutely incorrect this is not Prof
this is um gambling is never a good
thing you should never do it but if you
want to have fun craps is fun with
friends if you are prepared to lose
money the odds is by counter cards which
ilal it's
illegal illegal if you get caught no
it's no no no it's also not you can't
they just ask you to leave they can just
ban you it's not illegal though they can
they can ban you and they can make you
illegal for you to uh enter foot into
casinos but it's not illegal to count
cards you that's like saying it's
illegal to be good at playing like
American football like you know there
well because that's essentially what
you're doing like you're saying hey you
are too good at this you that is illegal
right but they have to make it fair no
all jokes aside uh I just like craps
because the most interactive game you
can play but that's the problem the more
interactive the game the faster it is to
uh lose money yeah and I feel that's a
bit stalk SC but I mean I will I don't
mind losing money because it's fun but
like the thing about craps that I do
like is that you can put a pretty
minimum bet down and just enjoy the
atmosphere of the table and not say I'm
I swear it always STS with a minimum B
it always starts with a minimum B when I
go back I'm going to get back that
10,000 I lost no I'm kidding but I broke
even on the trip cuz I didn't invest a
lot because you set limits obviously and
so I I just kind of had fun with hanging
out with friends and so that was that
was a good experience but won't be going
back anytime that's worth more than any
money in the world more than the world
real gambling was the friends we made
along the way Le we didn't lose the
friends we made one fun thing that
happened is that we we were doing craps
all that and this gentleman came over
and it was like he was locked in yeah he
was so serious every single turn he
would get the dice and he would line it
up perfectly and he'd put it on the
exact number he wanted for both Dice and
he would pinch it like this and he would
always throw it the same way wouldn't
say a word and wouldn't get excited
about anything and uh he was winning a
lot and then uh he was just kind of like
zoned in next day I got a twitchcon I'm
about to go on this show and this
producer guy comes up and he starts
doing stuff and I was like oh the guy
from last night on the table what he was
that guy and he was so jovial and happy
and talking and I was it was just such a
different energy and I was like yeah you
you won w a lot of money last night I
like I was on a Terr last night man I
was in the zone and I was like whoa okay
dude okay chill dude I just love to
imagine the dichotomy between that guy
who was like super [__] serious and
Pete just going what
every everyone you're supposed to like
bring your own energy to it yeah you're
right I was doing that you're I was just
let's go and I was I was definitely it
was my birthday and it was I was
slightly inebriated I was possibly maybe
shouting repeatedly every two minutes
we're printing money here I may or may
not have been shouting that and uh I
went on a pretty big tear though myself
and so it's very fun when it all goes
well cuz it's the game pays out a lot
but then it's verying when you lose oh
it's very miserable because the odds of
getting because the game is designed as
such that you have the highest odds of
losing and so it just keeps happening a
lot of times and then everyone's just
kind of like oh it's the thrill of that
one time you where you defy those the HT
but I I also love Japanese kind of old
style gambling like hanafuda or chinin
like these are just fun games that even
if you don't invest money the game
itself is fun to play so I I that's
where I come from I guess I mean I like
games with Stakes well me too so it
depends how high the stakes are though
you know
$25 no but I want a winner and I want a
loser yeah that's uh that's all that's
important but was that the first time
you went back to America in like since
Chris's chess boxing event uh the year
it was only briefly for like those 48
hours or so um I don't get a chance to
go back to the United States very often
but um it's always a it's always fun to
remember why I love living in Japan
so no it's a great it's a great great
nation it's just it's just not for me to
be honest I can't remember how long
you've been living in Japan now it's
almost 13 years 13 years damn yeah it's
wild when you put it into context like
that well you know I mean you're not
missing out on much that Taco Bell
tasting we did that was horrible hor
well it was okay I've never seen you so
coma toasted we did we tried the entire
Taco Bell menu right and he was I was
hurting I I realized I don't blame you
yeah I guess A lot's changed since I was
25 when I used to do this on like a
Friday but I still have a soft play for
Taco Bell I'll still ride and die with
it I love it all of it so you did not
fine L take but that's okay it's
whatever [__] horrendous it was cold
and it has the fastest shelf life of all
fast foods you literally need to eat it
in the car when you order it that is the
meta Jesus Christ this episode is
sponsored by boxu boxu isn't just a
Japanese snack box it is the premium
Japanese snack box guys boxer delivers
the experience of tasting authentic
Japanese snacks candies and tea sauce
directly from centuries old small family
businesses right to your door their
mission is to empower Japan's
traditional snack makers by sharing
their authentic food and stories with
the world my God it looks like you have
the boxu seasons of Japan box I do this
is the first boxu that you get after you
sign up to boxu and then every month
afterwards you get a special themed box
damn this is kind of like the special
hits that you can get uh that are
normally not available all year round
okay a box that has made it available
for your first month Joe what is this I
got here cuz that is Don Don Yaki it's a
Savory SBE that's fried and marinated in
ton o this is going to be good I can
already tell it's going to be really
addictive who needs British crisps
anymore when you have this also have
this tomato SBE similar style to it
savory tomato SBE you that crunch boys
oh yeah let's get 500 more of those so
if you want to give the gift of
authentic Japanese snacks this coming
holiday and support the channel in the
process click the link in the
description below and use the code trash
to get $15 off your first Boxer order
that's code trash at checkout for $15
off your first Boxer order back to the
episode I just lost no n November I was
wondering how how well you've adapted to
all like the let's say the online lingo
and the online memes I'm struggling
what's your favorite meme now I just
found out what down bad means I thought
yeah you you always you do keep saying
I'm down bad I thought I me like at the
gambling table I was like I'm down bad
like like I thought I was losing money
I'm down bad or it's like in the video
did you get weird looks from like the
ladies I get weird look
you down bad you look at the dealer and
you're like man I'm really down bad
today yeah makes sense to me or or like
I'll be playing like a video game and
like on Twitch or something and I'll be
losing subsequent like you know s game
I'm I'm down bad and then and then
everyone I guess that's similar to I
really am horny yeah yeah that's so
stupid we've adoped it's more like
desperate you're desperately one thing
you also kept saying at some point is
that you and as as a use for excited you
would say I'm bricked up yeah I'm all
that makes sense man all bricked up I'd
be like are you ready for the day he's
like I'm bricked up and I'm like what
the [__] so I'm taking those words back
so I like I'd be you know I'd be did you
ever have those words to no but I want
to reestablish what they mean so yeah
he'd be like all right today is a big
day we have twitch Rivals I'm like I'm
all bricked up I'm ready to go what does
that mean Bri bricked up means you have
a a [__] erection yeah it's erect
it's brick brick it's like a brick like
a
brick all right I mean technically
you're not wrong like you're so excited
you have an like I'm bricked up bricked
up body is ready but the meme stuff it
just happens too fast and
it ab and I'm okay with it it's like no
one's ever going to believe it and it's
fine but when I was the age where it was
more accessible to me it it was
something that was natural memes or
joking or or you know certain vernacular
or certain okay what what what are you
some of your like classic memes then
actually if I'm being 100% honest I'm
pretty ashamed of what in the early n
the late '90s early 2000s a lot of the
the meme stuff was really offensive and
so yeah like a lot of slows it was just
really bad and like and I think that
even near the tail end we all kind of
got away from that and it was like but I
would say things like do people still
say that's sick or badass
or I mean like memes only came out like
like 10 years ago like advice true
that's not true that is true wait wait
Your Meme history memes have been around
since like late '90s early 2000 we
talking I swear to God the [__] cat
hieroglyphics in like the [__]
ancient Egypt those were like their
version of M no no no swear down swear
down man kill kill Roy is the original
meme the World War II little guy you dra
oh yeah that's I was talking
specifically about internet memes been
around since the internet no they
haven't no they hav no the wild west of
the internet was a glorious place where
there was no rules established there was
like the best page in the universe this
was the most popular site to talk about
jokes about from this one guy and it's
no longer really referenced anymore at
all the first meme I can genuinely think
of is all your Bas are belong to us I
mean that's the classic fire all Zig can
you
what is the first internet meme cuz I'm
I'm genuinely curious going say it was
probably an advice animal or the dancing
baby baby no that's from a TV show rle
copter copter
dance uh all your Bas belong to us there
we go all your Bas belong to us so I was
law that's that's where if uh a
conversation goes long enough on the
internet it'll eventually reference
Hitler yeah so that was yeah a trap yeah
but see like hon dance that's a yeah
that's this is still not 98
yep there I was Dancy that's Ali mcel
came yeah just looking at that graph is
really fun yeah it's true it's but see
like that's but the internet really came
out like 95 96 when it started becoming
pervasive with like H like with Napster
and downloading music and there was no
memes yet there was and like even that
stuff it was like 95 96 [__] way yeah
and then it was shut
down I I was I was born after Napster no
you were not I guess I was when
Metallica ruined all the fu Metallica
said [__] Napster yeah that was good
times man it was good times that's an
amazing zero and like all of the kind of
but like I I would say meme culture
didn't become meme culture until really
Justin TV or twitch when it was more
universally adopted I totally agree
because I remember there was this moment
in my like let's say like YouTube
history where everyone you know I've
always tried to make comedic kind of
videos try try to like put jokes in my
videos and somewhere along the lines
they stop calling my jokes jokes and
they start calling them memes I can't
tell when that transition was but I
never changed the ways I started making
my videos that's true you never hear
someone go oh that was a good joke yeah
yeah yeah right oh that Meme was
killer he's meing joking yeah and I
don't know when that transition happened
but I remember when I first saw it I was
like I'm not making a meme I'm just just
making a joke I don't know what the
difference is I guess if it's like more
referential it would be a meme do you
have a favorite era there was like the
ones where you would have like a Bad
Luck Brian that was a whole era like
pictur inspiral posters the black uh
backrop and then the white outline the
uninspirational posters gingers they
have no
souls and then I'd say like after that
one and then bad luck and stuff you had
like the gifts were a big part of
everyday conversation for about four
years I mean they still I'd say they're
slightly SK cring gifts are cringe gifts
are getting more cringe now now it's
static images coming back I'm try I'm
trying to think because it depends on if
the GIF is something that you've seen so
many [__] times before you know if it
if it's like a fresh one OC huh original
content well there's the one that's been
going around recently which is the one
where it's Vince McMahon going like oh
yeah like this oh that's more I I
wouldn't put that in like gift territory
though that's just more of a funny video
meme I don't know I think reacting to
like how many times when you use Twitter
or instant messenger do you go to the do
you go to a gift reply these days I mean
I I've never done that okay but I've
I've just never like I mean I did that
on like MSN and [__] but that's like 20
years ago do do you do you send emojis
when you message someone I Emoji I Emoji
I know you I know you Emoji emojis I
know you Emoji yeah sometimes I feel
like I shouldn't but I sometimes do I do
it just to make sure that like my tone
is conveyed yeah sometimes I look at a
sentence I'm like it's not getting
across something's missing oh crying
laughing emoji that's it I feel like
feel it feels very like like an exchange
otherwise if there's no emo con it's
like we are sending each other necessary
information and that's it whereas an
emojicon I feel like adds more context
adds emotion to it my favorite ones are
the ones where like when you're texting
someone and you're clearly trying to be
sarcastic but if you just read the text
it doesn't sound sarcastic until you put
the skull emoji on yeah yeah then that's
the then it becomes I love the skull
emoji it's so good I don't think I can
use it when you put a skull emoji
immediately it's like it could be the
most it's like it could be the most
positive thing and then immediately it
becomes sarcastic I think I'm out on
that one I think well I mean I like it
but I think if I used it they'd be like
okay Pete you're nice try you
and it's like getting carded at the the
Barcade I trust me I'm still like had a
great dinner fork and knife and I'm like
you still that's that's a bit that's but
that's what calls to me so anything else
would be trying too hard to do you just
see old emojis like that no I mean there
are some that are universally okay like
the Clapping one can be useful yeah it
just depends on the context but I'm not
really familiar with how to tweet yet so
and I'm not ever going to be so I just
kind of probably better off to yeah y
but lot's changed since the old days
yeah do you remember like Tech speak at
all oh yeah Elite speak kind was it
called lead speak 1337 speak like I like
onor you and like you yeah all that [__]
was awesome yeah like dude I still
remember the PW and
pone you got pwned you got pwned like
said of pawn it was prawn prawn yeah
it's not still I still use that as like
a joke prawn yeah yeah it's a great PR n
yeah PR zero in yeah but lead speak was
even during the era we it was always
ridiculed like it was only used
derisively to make fun of it in of
itself I I don't feel like it was I feel
like there are he making fun of you no
no I I I felt like there was a period
where people unironically said it and
then after that kind of cycle like went
away then people said I think it had a
very short lifespan where people were
actually using it unironically and a
very long lifespan of people using it
ironically yeah that might have been it
that's how most of my my vocabulary
forms just saying [__] ironically and
then I'm like wait I'm actually I think
I'm doing this unironically yeah totally
that's so haunted like dude was never in
my vocabulary I never said I never said
dude but I started using it ironically
because it was just a funny word that
was that was me with bruh and then now I
I I run dabing yeah that was me with
dabbing 2016 every photo no way remember
the Joey dabbing era oh yeah did you
plank uh I still don't know what that
means I thought that was a sex thing I
thought it's like Prince William likes
getting planked I thought that was a
phrase what is that not the phrase or is
that like Peg I think it might be pegged
does Prince I don't know what either of
I thought planking and pegging was the
same meme no so I think it's pegged yeah
pegs so I I I saw that did you Pake and
Peg no so I because I was unfamiliar
with both phrases I just used them
interchangeably I just never did any of
them I see I just kind I just imagine
people being like yeah so I saw my
friend the other day doing the pegging
challenge well pretty epic video so
what's planking is that where you do the
thing on your your wrist wait yeah
actually technically but the P the
pegging the the planking challenge was
where you would literally just lie down
face down on the ground like you're a
plank of wood and the more extreme of
place you would do it the the bigger
challenge it was and there was like a
lot of people who died doing this
because they would doing them on like
train tracks on like train tracks and
like on like the the handrails of like
uh balconies and stuff like that and
they just fall off yeah people people
died doing this why you looking at me
like you said it this also reminds me
what he didn't realize oh this was bad
this sucks I thought harambe died of
natural
causes I don't understand I thought it
was a tragic story and then everybody
told me he was shot this is [__]
stupid yeah he was assassinated he was
murdered yeah so that's why everyone
wanted Justice for him bro harambe would
be disappointed how do you think he just
died of natural C I I knew the child
fell in yeah and and what he just had a
heart attack I thought heed I thought he
died of shock and then everyone was like
they need bigger fences so to protect
these apes and I thought like he the the
the child fell down and then he was like
and and I think that's what killed him
and then somebody was like no they
called in like the zoo sniper staff yeah
they I can't the video is like
absolutely horrifying like he's
literally dragging this child and that's
not his fault I just couldn't believe it
because I'm pretty sure I was in Japan
during this time and so news travel when
when was that
2016 yeah and so I missed all this I I
missed rest in peace rest in peace now
that I know you were brutally murdered
he didn't just well since you're in
Japan did you like ever was graun ever
no or con for president or something I
don't know oh my God I you just bringing
back like a core memory
that Cony is a corrupted Ugandan
warlord I thought it was like a
Grassroots movement York hire who would
hire Ugandan children into his armor
well well I mean
okay whole so I thought this was like a
green party thing in the United
States and it's it's
like how did you think this well because
it was con 2012 was the slogan yeah I
understand but since I only have heard
the slogan I don't have any reference
point because it would never come up in
day-to-day discussions while you're in
Japan and so
there's
yeah and so you know you miss a lot of
those flash point things that are
important to a lot of people from
because but how did you acate hot attack
har I just thought it was a tragic I
don't know I just made it the [__] up it
didn't make sense that they would shoot
an ape in an enclosure I just thought
that was that that's why it was a
tragedy yeah I get mean it makes sense
now and so is Con 2012 a tragedy
apparently so like I'm learning con
story is a little bit different well I'm
just saying these were some sort of meme
or like not memes but these were moments
that people had in the western speaking
world and I I was locked out so like in
which this is going to sound we in which
year did you kind of like sh cut
yourself off or like you know C become
cut off from like internet culture 2011
until about
2016 that's when so many good events
happened is that because of Japan like
moving there yeah when I my first year I
was in got and I didn't even have a
phone for my first two months like I
just went completely off the grid and I
couldn't afford like a uh like a laptop
or anything I didn't have a computer
until I started like Twitch streaming in
20 21 2020 but I'm also jealous that you
get to like relive these it's prun like
in a fresh eye yeah well it's it's
sometimes tough when you don't have any
context and you're obviously wrong yeah
because like so many so many modern
memes nowaday require like 10 different
level of context for like a single image
and yeah there's a lot
ofay mes there a lot of memes that are
like four layers of memes in one it's
like what is this who is this for what's
the latest meme that you learned of I
mean it's it's like it's so hard to keep
track I mean like even the one we just
referenced about Vince McMahon you know
like you see them so much now that I
feel like I actually kind of preferred
not being a part of meme culture like
there's a real freeing
of of just not having to reference this
for comedy but at the same time it's
like being at a concert or like a
sporting event or a twitch stream where
you do feel part of a collective group
when you do know what's being referenced
AB I'm obviously out of that one one
thing I was surprised by is uh I because
initially you didn't talk about it much
but you have an intense love for sports
I do I'm very I love sports sports
literally all of them like I I really
enjoy following Sports I enjoy playing
sports what's your favorite my favorite
is baseball and uh because that's it's
America's pastime and it was something
that was very closely connected with me
and my dad and so like that has that
familial thing yeah but basketball um
baseball I've always wanted this phrase
America Past Time American past time
what what does that mean so to put it
simply as an American baseball has such
a deeply rooted history with when we
were coming out of the depression and
you may have heard of player named like
Babe Ruth he's a famous there's a candy
bar is also named Baby Ruth he was like
great one of the greatest bball probably
arguably the greatest baseball player
ever there's even terms now you'd say
it's a ruthian task which like a
Herculean task the reason baseball's so
closely entwined with American history
was that one guy became the first famous
sports player in American history so
much so that it we believed if Ruth can
do these things by God so can we and it
was like that part of American motiv
motivational and so I mean baseball for
over a 100 years was such a vital part
of American culture until the past 30
and then it's dead I mean I feel it was
kind of the same when baseball was
introduced to Japan as well very much
like cuz that was you know uh post you
know World War II and everything and you
know it was before the economic bubble
happened and I feel like a lot of sports
that were imported from other countries
to Japan that are now massive like
baseball uh you know kind of used to
being like yeah all right you know we
got this yeah right on I think that's
why that's such a huge kind of like
sphere of like American kind of like
Fascination here with a lot of people
from Japan oh yeah I I actually just
went to a bar last week and the guy
running the bar was uh the best way I
can describe it was just an American
otaku like that's great though like and
it was like so he was like this old guy
and he just had like baseball cards and
everything those are called America Boos
like America
Boos yeah and he was like yeah I was
like watching the game and I was like
what game he was like all the games
every every single game well like in
Japan especially like past 5 years like
America core like that kind of whole
like looking at America through the like
rose tinted glasses like when it comes
like style and fashion and just like
decor and stuff it's huge in Japan yeah
yeah yeah so many secondhand stores are
just like selling these like America
core items and you show this to an
America and they're like America doesn't
there is always a sport game happening
every single night like of like a big
league it seems in America almost
certainly yeah seemed like every single
night you'd go into a bar and there
would be a game on it's great and so
that that got like through college the
NBA has 40 games and 40 nights during
the playoffs so it's a pretty like
nostalgic thing to be working on exam
papers and just know that you're going
to have some sport on in the background
so yeah um but I mean obviously when you
look at me it doesn't I don't give off
The Vibes that I I love sports but I it
is something that I still follow pretty
regularly to this day I mean I I think
liking Sports and following Sports was
kind of like at least my age she kind of
like a given and it was like more out of
the norm to not follow Sports and now I
think just because we're so integrated
into like let's say nerd culture
especially online culture now it's now
you're like the outcast if you do follow
Sports if you are passionate about
sports I I don't watch a lot of sports
but I really love the the stories that
have been that have taken place in
sports uh even if I don't care about the
the the sport at all but you know
there's like some American stories that
from like American football that I've
heard that I'm like that sounds really
cool but I don't care no no the Olympics
the Olympics do this the best when they
always get some Narrative of like this
one person's swimming goal and then you
get all wrapped into it for that one
event and yeah American Sports are good
kind of over like that in the I think
what like American Sports football in
the UK they're really good at like
having these longstanding stories that
develop over the course of the years I
watched that Emperor lemon video about
the 72 dolphins or whatever oh the
undefeated team yeah yeah that's really
cool like when it's framed in such a way
it's like oh this is great like I I love
watching documentaries and and uh movies
or whatever about about sport but I
don't want to watch it week by week a
lot of the time unless isless is the
Legends Final sometimes worth it though
when you have when you have a team do do
you have any teams you support I do I
have my my beanie that in my my bag here
it's my Kansas City Royals beanie which
is a baseball team they are the worst
team in the Maj but I will never forget
that in 2015 they they won the World
Series and it was the first time in 30
years that this had happened and to be
at school when this was unfolding and
being a part of it oh man there's
nothing better and then they immediately
went back to the worst team in the
entire world epod is sponsored by vessie
always you guys know that we absolutely
love vessie over here at trash taste we
all have vessie shoes but any time of
the year rain sleep snow shine because
they are just that versatile waterproof
and comfortable but did you guys know
that V has so much more that they have
for you guys to get your hands on right
now look at these gloves that Conor has
on right now very comfortable vertile
fitting slim and I like that they're
perfect for every single season
absolutely and most importantly like
every other product they are 100%
waterproof guys and here in Japan now
it's turning into winter time literally
we felt it on the way here guys it was
raining it's cold it's drab but it's
okay because right here I have their new
coat the overcast it's 100% waterproof
with a stretchy shell soft fleece lining
and a relaxed fit you look ready for the
winter season and what are those shoes
you guys have right there well these are
the alto Joey I'm glad you asked these
are a 100% winter essential tailed for
winter with extra grippy souls and they
have temperature rating go as low as
zero andus 5 during medium activities
like walking so you can head to v.com
trash test right now and dive into their
bfcm sale that's the Black Friday Cyber
Monday sale from November the 17th to
November the 27th go to v.com traste and
enjoy exclusive discounts during vess's
biggest sale of the Year back to the
episode what's been like some of the
most favorite things you've discovered
because you you know T every time I Tau
you you had to like period not just with
memes but with kind of like so many
pieces of media that you kind of just
like Miss in terms of like pop culture
has there been anything you've
discovered that has been like
integrating to like now modern pop
culture that you're like damn this is
cool experiencing this for the first
time whether it be like a TV show yeah I
think I have not seen a movie in 10
years isn't that wild like that can't be
true the last movie I saw was with you
in Los Angeles oh that was the first
time I'd been to a theater in 10 years
what yeah DN you must have watched
only on the airplanes and I as a theater
major yeah I mean but like but I don't
take that many planes right so you're
talking about like going to a theater
I'm talking about having Netflix and and
watching a movie on a Tuesday night
before the movie you watched with Connor
what was the last movie you watched the
one from 10 years ago oh um it was that
Batman movie that was dog [__] and
that's what turned me off
of the final Nolan one okay oh the Bane
one dark rises so bad yeah dark KN RIS
bad it was awful
so many holes and and I
could it was and like I like those I
like Chris it was okay it was I like
Chris for Nolan I like the two movies
those were good those were very good I
like you just think the last one was
[__] it was not only [__] it was
unwatchable garage oh
my unable garbage I wouldn't go that far
but it was definitely out of the three
Nolan films it was definitely the worst
one and I like all the actors in it but
every single moment it's just like PL
dude it it goes the the in order it goes
from best to worst The Dark Knight The
Dark Knight Rises Batman Begins I
thought I thought Batman Begins was
better than I thought begins was better
than Dark Knight Rises just because Dark
Knight Rises I think had so many things
going on people are dumb all the people
those people are from the Cincinnati Zoo
we we have
250,000 a I mean look if you like the
movie it's fine but they should have
called it The Dark Knight DSX Machina
because anything that needed to happen
at any point to progress the movie Just
magically happened and I can't stand
when they do that in drama it's not a
it's not like his best movie uh I don't
think literally play RPG games that's
that's all it is I am flawed that is all
it is all it is is [__] I know I
understand where I can come across as a
hypocrite that's not what we're talking
about but uh I welcome to trash Tas
everyone first time this has ever
happened in the history of trash taste
who would have thought hot takes on
trash taste but I think that yeah I saw
that in the theaters and I didn't like
it and so that was 2012 yeah that's the
last time I went to the theat that's
just like I'm never seeing a movie again
I was like I'm good but I I will say the
thing that I'm happy as a huge theater
nerd and like you know someone who
really respects drama I think we did go
through a nice golden age of Television
that I did miss out on but I'm happy
existed with your breaking bads and your
Game of Thrones oh you miss breaking
bads I've seen them since right but like
I'm really glad that in a in an era now
where movies I feel kind just been
rehashed in kind of not a lot of
originality These Days TV not not
there's exceptions but TV really came
into its own with some awesome gripping
narratives and I think that's that's
cool TV has gotten really good in the
past like 20 years it was really bad
from before 2008 or so it's cuz it was
like the way that they syndicated TV
shows it like it had to be 25 episodes
had to run for so long and and if the
network wanted to change the plot they
could just change the plot and so it's
it's changed a lot how TV is made yeah I
I don't know I I don't know if that's
true I just I'm trying I'm trying to
think of like the classic TV shows but
well look at it like this you had like
things like Seinfeld or friends or
Malcolm in the Middle most popular
shows we sitcoms right we were long
running TV shows and now I guess you
have more narratively driven shows as
well but I guess yeah I guess like
before I'm trying to think of like some
way more shows get made now yeah yeah I
mean that's that's true um you had The
Sopranos the wire those are the ones
that broke the old even when I was still
there they were like doing that was like
HBO only yeah they were the only people
trying to do like I guess that makes
sense yeah it's been but it's been cool
to see people really enjoy television
again yeah that's been a missing thing I
mean I I I think the rise of that came
from just streaming platforms so now you
because because the people are enjoying
not know if you ever remember it was
like box set culture where you would buy
the box set of all of the seasons of
show the the problem with TV shows
before is that you had to tune in at the
TV at the regular time that's why you
buy the DVDs yeah yeah and sometimes you
just couldn't like do that 10 minutes is
an ad so now with like online streaming
culture you get you don't have to worry
about if the audience has seen previous
episodes because you can just assume
they have yeah I do miss that though
like I think the closest we used to call
it water cooler TV shows where you stand
around the water cooler and discussed
last night's most relevant episode of
Dex has anyone ever done that I
am
yes I would argue trash taste is that
yeah it's like like you just fil an
episode about that about Attack on Titan
Water no no has anyone ever because I
I've always heard about water cooler
moment yeah this wouldn't be a term if
people hadn't done it we don't just say
oh it's the [__] elephant talk anyone
who works at an office I think has done
that it's because uh if you don't smoke
back in the day you only had the chance
to get up and stand around and like
slowly up your teacup no cuz in the UK
it was like the making tea talk that's
we didn't have water speaking of I
brought you guys a little taste of
England I forgot
about I thought somebody I I I had met a
viewer recently and they they came to
Japan and they right my grandmother rest
in peace she did not get shot or
anything but she was why do why do you
have to PR that natural di natural
Americans have to pre get shot and she
was Welsh and so she's from that Village
that I can't pronounce
Lord of the Rings um and so but my
favorite snack growing up was these
these dodgy Jammers or Jammy Dodgers
Jammy Dodgers J Dog do you got Jammy
Dodgers so I have I have a Jammy Dodgers
good that's the new packaging yeah it's
the new new packaging these wait you had
these growing up ah yeah these are these
are really good no nasty stuff we're
Jammy enough yeah so your cousins really
liked you if you had these available at
the the kind of the these are the best
biscuits right not the jaffa cakes it's
not the digestives the digestives are
kind of like the the the yeah I'll Stand
the digestives these are definitely more
fancy if you had these you kind of a bit
more of a bougie family yeah yeah yeah W
yeah will you crack it over have Jam do
I I forgot have youever had one of these
I have once or twice yeah they are
really good with a teeth really likes
you do need to have them with a tee but
they taste pretty good on there I
probably should have uh I meant to give
them to you after the show but we
started talking about
go they are goated as you say I can't
how do you I'm not British what do you
mean you opened it like I see I must say
I'm bricked up I'm
all there you go man these are these are
fantastic there you go thank you very
much actually I hate raspberry so I just
I'm down bad right now oh wait here's
one in here down bad I'm down bad man I
am so down bad for a Jammy
dog if you hate The Dark Knight Rises
and you think that's the most like awful
film what are what are films you
actually like L give give me give me
give me a five what's your inside into
Pete's mind of what his tastes are
actually like top five films go
yeah all right let's go it's really
really tough question obviously but I
would say my easily first is
Ghostbusters it's my favorite movie
that's a
personal it's a classic and it was at
the time the most expensive comedy ever
made in the history of movies which is
pretty pretty wild to think about number
two is LA Confidential a fantastic crime
Noir film that's really really great and
if you haven't seen it Guy Pierce
Russell Crow Kim Bay
singer it didn't win the Oscar right cuz
I Titanic came out the same so dumb am I
crazy the you're right it's it's a
travesty uh this one kind of
controversial because it's made by a
horrific scumbag named Roman palansky
who is a horrible dude but if you
separate art and artist Chinatown with
Jack Nicholson one of the finest noirs
you'll ever see I happen to prescribe to
the fact that sha Shank Redemption is
the most rewatchable movie I I really
lik a great movie it's a great
I I haven't seen a single person like
get bored of sh shine Redemption no I
don't think that you can and so and then
my final one to round out it's so hard
to choose just five but the theater guy
in me would probably say 12 Angry Men
cuz we're going to go old school with it
which is just a nice one setting but
like that's when you were born right I
was actually um I was 10 so I had to
study I got to get another one you know
if we were I feel like it's like asking
someone favorite game it's impossible
you got to go by genre or era he just
answered it he didn't mean that he he he
said ginin I think under he was like
genin Mass Effect I said Mass Effect
even though the third ones like The Dark
Knight yes I like the third Mass Effect
my God that's actually my favorite Mass
Effect we have a real problem here this
is worse than I think the [__]
complaints about the ending were
overblown I don't know it's people were
just like complaining I still think
think like obviously like from like I
guess like a critical standpoint the
second one was like the best the bridge
yeah yeah but I just like seeing the uh
send off to all the characters so that's
why the third is my favorite I feel like
did you ever play Mass Effect Trilogy
you can skip it did you play it good job
so this is just a one-onone all I'm
going to say is this to everybody who's
played Mass Effect you know I'm right
when I say that how exciting was it to
recruit the rakite queen or to make all
these choices with the kog
all of them to be a resource at the war
table come on that was they didn't
matter nothing none of your choices
mattered in the end chooes don't matter
I think choic is kind of overrated in my
opinion in video games it's kind of
overrated you've convinced me
yeah literally lost [__] I've changed my
mind it's like that Simpsons Mee where
the guys
like just give me a linear story I don't
want to make my own choices I'm a
[__] dumbass you think you think you
should you think I should be trusted to
make the best choices in the video games
no we were literally just discussing
this the last episode what do you think
about multiple endings in video
games yeah see I knew
I get to role playay my charg player
it's the best what what's the argument
against multiple endings sometimes just
shoehorned in it's all right yeah you
don't have to do those ones yeah like I
I I think uh like I I said this in like
a previous episode where I think if you
have multiple endings it kind of like
detracts from the impact of some of the
endings you could have because you know
when you have a definitive ending if you
think of like if you could choose your
own ending for a movie would you you
know um I understand what you're saying
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah definitely I
prefer one solid Artic one artistic
Vision that the director had in mind
sure and by having multiple endings you
kind of like I I guess the storytelling
like power of that to me kind of like
gets detracted you know usually games
have a a Canon ending though right like
like a true ending yeah and so like my
best example oh we're going so old it's
like Chrono Trigger which has nine
different endings or thereabouts and
each one is unique enough where you
would go out of your way to see a
different outcome but you know that
there's only one true actual ending but
dude I played I played it and I got all
nine endings yeah me too and like but I
feel like go to game yeah and you can I
think there's usually pretty strong
evidence to suggest this is what
probably led to the actual events have
you ever like read like a Choose Your
Own Adventure book yeah or yeah remember
Goosebumps that sh watch like band
snatch on Netflix I still haven't got
around to that I haven't gone around to
that one yeah it's it's the fact that I
didn't want to I didn't want to watch
something and have to choose exactly
right exactly how about this though play
goes to space I've
seen it's a great own adventure well one
of my favorite movies that I didn't
mention is an old comedy called clue
like the board game cludo you know it
doesn't sound like it' make for a great
movie but one of the cool things that it
did in the theaters was depending on
which theater you went to it had one of
three different endings because like the
board game there's no real when you play
it always comes out different I think
that's an awesome idea to have an a
random ending depending on which theater
you go to that's I thought that was it's
really great I think that sounds awful
you should try that sounds awful a great
that's kind it kind of sounds cool
sounds like that's a great way to get
people to pay to watch the movie three
times I think to me that more sounds
like a gimmick than it does a kind of
like autistic hey take my money bro take
all right well it's hard to convince
that's just me it was really fun it's a
really great very smallart yeah it was
really that's like the ' 80s so they
were
innovating yeah is there any games you
like that AR RPGs lately yeah well I do
believe that one of these games that's
sweeping the world is this one where you
match fruits together right oh my gosh
and I played it for like 3 hours and set
the high score out of everybody body
that we know and so that what's the
problem why can't you do well it's so
easy you it pisses me off how close you
were to Greatness and you stopped yeah I
don't need greatness I already it's
defined with the high score was you
could have got the Fable double Su do it
you want to explain what this is so
basically it's a child's game you stack
up you stack up different fruits you
match two strawberries you get a grape
two grapes mean a meon or whatever and
all these bozos are trying their best to
beat it I needed that game for like an
hour it's really funny watching these
like fully grown ass adults just like
playing this children's game it
forious but for me the actually to
answer your question truthfully every
genre on the table I get labeled a lot
as a retro gamer because I like y
retro this is actually it but uh I
actually prefer you know a lot of the
modern games as well so it's like
anything and all game like well not that
one but yeah it's like uh I just love
video games and it's it's what are some
of the modern games then uh what's come
out recently that's been pretty good is
things like lies of P or you know
Spider-Man 2 or what are the big games
that have come out that have cuz this
year's been pretty bleak I yeah has it
well Bal Gate 3 you play [__] Legend
of Zelda I thought Legend of Zelda
breath of the boring uh wild to that
that is that is an LTE that's such an El
wait what it's all right I I I I'm fine
with dying on that I don't [__] with the
whole building on the new one I don't I
don't like it no the building is the
best part I don't like that and it's
like it's like Minecraft I hate that I
hate that if I want to play Minecraft
play Minecraft no I feel like if you I
feel like we talked about this last time
too I feel you say breath of the boring
I feel like if you replace link with any
other character it's it's going to be
the same great game that it already is
but this not a Zelda game it's just oh
no I don't include it as a Zelda game
well there you go see that's if we're
going to not but it's still a great game
it is a great I mean like yeah but I
think it's like like it's it's kind of
just cashing in on putting you know
there's there's there's breath of the
wild and tear of the kingdom and then
there's every other Zelda game in my
mind that's that's exactly how I feel so
sad for me but yeah I think like balers
Gate 3 was great but these are RPGs
though
yeahp than RPG but I mean like I'm just
trying to think Elden ring was last year
yeah Elden ring was last year I feel
like this year has been kind
of I I feel like I don't know hey Super
Mario RPG remakes coming out though I
will be playing that on
out comes this comes out this weekend
weekend oh wow hope it's good it almost
feels like there there's like my my
backlog of every time I complete a game
I'm it seems like every time I'm just in
the cust of completing a game there's a
new like [__] massive game that comes
out at least this year 3 remake they all
make all the game studos make an
agreement to time out their games to get
gone boy I feel like the the tener of
this episode has been I have really
horrible takes on everything no is that
a normal trash taste thing you fit right
in they've heard all of our opinions so
we just want to you know want ask about
your some new fresh bad takes about we
need some new material good games yeah
no we want we want the bad takes but
good takes are boring P good takes are
boring yeah it's pretty wild though to
to think about you harambe take is
definitely my favorite though that's not
even a take think that's fol that a take
yeah but it's a funny believe that
happened I'm very upset natural causes
natural causes died of a heart attack
from that poor child who fell in I
imagined like in my mind harambe was
wearing like some bath robe and it was
cinched up and it
was just just died it's like damn I
can't believe this child fell in the
[__] rest in peace rest in peace I guess
you are right I don't know nothing's
been out man yeah this Sho has been
pretty boring for video games I think
because I don't care about Spider-Man I
don't care about Spider-Man it's good it
good yeah but I heard it was like just
the first game DLC I mean I mean I
played it for the story and that was
pretty much it um sometimes more you
final like that's crazy you count Final
Fantasy 16 as a big release but we're
not counting RPGs right like we're not
counting that's the thing this year and
early next year is all RPGs this is like
the year of
RPGs we are e the shooters are kind of
out now Star Wars Jedi Survivor I've
been playing
that street street fighter six oh I that
would probably be oh that was a big
relas that was probably my favorite game
this year
oh yeah yeah that looks insane as a
consumer I like to watch it to follow it
yeah no no I mean I I mean like we got
to play it first we played it but I've
not like gotten into it oh I CU it's
it's a fighting game fighting game
fighting games are like obviously it's
his own genre but I feel like out of
every genre it's one of the hardest
genres to get into but I think Street
Fighter 6 did make an effort to to the
easy
controls yeah but yeah games are out
this year it's kind of uh it's a great
time to be a streamer [__] watermelon
game man yeah I'm not too concerned with
that I already beat it yeah it's easy
and uh I wish I could beat it I will say
like one thing that I'm I'm not proud of
much obviously I I don't I don't have a
lot of things that I hang my hat on but
I am glad that all these years starting
with like the Commodore and the Atari
and the Nintendo uh when we were at
twitch Rivals we had to play that party
anim oh that was so fun yeah and I still
feel in these these ancient hands if you
give me a controller or a game I can
adapt quickly enough you're making a
sound like you're like an old grandmas
or something I'm telling you man it's a
young man's game like his third eye
opens it does yeah we we uh we competed
in a ultimate twitch Rivals it was
really fun to be fair uh and uh we had
to do a series of different like casual
things like physical and game and party
animals was one of them and all of us
were pretty bad except for we never
played yeah we had a guy called five up
with us who was pretty good and kind of
helped us uh and we ended up winning
first place yeah we got first place in
that yeah in that event and then when
the physical stuff I that's when age the
mind was willing but the body was unable
but the the crazy thing is like I I do
feel getting to play games and just
still having that because like Esports
players whatever they're like 22 and
they're retired they're like I can't
play rocket League anymore 22 is like
old ancient yeah you need you need to
come up when you're like 16 17 well this
is the oldest uh this League of Legends
competition is the oldest it's ever been
the players so what's the average age 19
I think it's like 25
now
12 that's a fortnite competition me
League of Legends has G to a point now
where um I'm not sure how many new
players it's getting it's a lot of the
older players cuz they the old players
just keep coming back every time and uh
we had we had one of we had one person
in the league uh world's final this year
that was like a dad it was like in his
30s he was getting his ass clapped by
like
everyone there we go according to a
survey conducted by ESPN in 2018 the
average age of professional League of
Legends Esports players is 21.2 years
old that's crazy but now in this this
world is a yeah it's a 24 to 25 yeah
it's generally older which is kind of
cool I I like that it's it's getting to
that point now where people have been in
the Esports for so long and they're
aging still keeping up with kids who are
19 you got you got a chance Pete you got
a chance well to me it's like I just are
you are you into competitive games not
particularly but I
I well do you have a competitive comp
you have a competitive he gets for
[__] comp are you kidding me this
man's competitive well I mean it's like
it sucks when you're so good at a lot of
the games that I play no I'm kidding but
are you are are you one of those
[__] who opens up like a you
know like a game of OverWatch he bides
his time he waits for the game if let's
just try our best yes guys it's okay
it's okay guys or do you have like a
toxic gamer side to I don't have a toxic
gamer well he's very gracious and the
moment he knows that he can kick your
ass he'll go full
toxic you're so bad why are you so bad
at the game I just can't understand how
bad you are it makes no sense that you
play so long no I think like for me in
when you have a group of friends who
play video games back in the day there's
always one of you who are going to be
fundamentally better than the rest of
the group and it's not fun to Lord that
over each other and try to do like let's
play Golden ey where I always win first
place or we're going to play Halo where
I'm always on the Stacked team right so
for me that's always been kind of the
role that I've been in but when you play
other groups who are competitive you
quickly learn that you're at the
midlevel of like gaming so I feel like
I've never really purposely tried to be
in a I was in like a Team Fortress
classic clan when I was 15 like you know
hell yeah the old game that was like
number one oh no no we were it was so
different back then you had to like
organize when to fight each other and
you had to get on Roger Wilco or vent
trillo which were old TeamSpeak um oh my
God team speak feels ancient
to didn't exist there was no built-in
clients and so you had to do things kind
of very differently because there was
nothing in the game itself to set it up
but other than that being competitive I
just I just really like the Challen of
applying all the games I've played I can
see patterns relatively quickly and I I
find that to be very exciting I'm such a
nerd this is so bad it's like could
forand could recognize patents quickly
but thought that harambe died I feel
like I put my St points you just are you
just like gaming Rainman right now I'm
like it's like yeah get to controlling
you like well it's really I can't stop
this power no but what it is is it's
it's something that I'm so thankful it's
so cool to have grown up with them all
oh totally like to not have to come into
like my first console was a 360 I can't
imagine not starting You' literally been
there since the beginning that's that's
dope as hell it's pretty awesome like
trade that for much think of the modern
gaming industry then I think it's it's
really great I think that what I like
the most is the how Indies have come up
because I think Indie developers are
basically people my age who really miss
a lot of the games that we used to play
they're saying we can still innovate on
the limitations that the old consoles
had and make these cool games and then
you get some really cool AAA titles here
and there that are still fun to kind of
you know put some time into but yeah
it's a good place I think it's it's like
the thing about AAA games is that it
just feels like it's you know it's kind
of like watching a Blockbuster movie you
don't get as much personality not as
much
like individual expression but you know
it's it's like nice to like get up you
kind of like feel like you're like
getting the pop corn out and just
watching a Blockbuster movie in a
theater lately the meme is that all
indie games are Rog likes yeah it is a
big Trend right there's a huge portion
of that I Sid scroller Rog likes just
any Rog likes card deck card Builder Ro
Rog likes or whatever but you know I
mean it's just because obviously that
given the tools there's only like you
know it's a little harder to develop
certain things yeah I love R I'm not
complaining yeah I like I like I feel
like those are it's really hard to
create something narratively strong that
has a specific vision and Rogue likes
allow a lot of player and Creator
expression but I still really like like
it's all RPGs but like chain deos and
sea of stars which are made by like one
guy or a team of two or three that's
pretty impressive that there's like one
single game there inscription I liked a
lot great like well yeah that part one's
amazing part two is pretty good three's
three is pretty bad but part one is
amazing amazing I was wondering was
there a moment where you got like
interested in acting cuz you when we've
talked to Lis you haven't talked about
much about like your path into trying to
be an actor I just know you tried to be
one well tried there was some successes
in there it's a I'm not a complete
flameout where I just tried and um yeah
it was it was during it was during
middle school and like high school when
I had a lot of trouble cuz I wasn't in
the normal classes for different reasons
but I found theater as like a thing
where I could be really challenged with
some of the it's really hard to be a a
stage actor cuz oh I'm sure and I took
it really seriously and so after high
school where I I learned that oh it's
not just shouting when you're angry or
emoting when you're sad when I went to
college it was pretty formative and I I
worked actually I got hired at a radio
station as a DJ like right out of high
school and that was really hard because
the people I worked with were so awful
it probably the worst job experience
I've ever had how were they awful just
well rude this is this is a six minute
story is that okay it's take yeah yeah I
wish it had a funny ending but oh well
so basically I was taking a broadcasting
class in college and there was this
amazing weatherman for the local news
who was teaching it and his advice was
like if you ever get your foot in the
door don't take it out because these
opportunities are hard to come by sure
and I was like that does make a lot of
sense and then there was a radio station
in Kansas City called
z95.7 today's hit music [__] music and
then uh you they came into our our class
to give like the morning show DJ and the
morning shows in America are the most
popular because you get like you're in
traffic and it's a lot of like joking
and talking and less music so they came
F sounds and F sounds and sound effects
and yes GTA radio but exactly and he
came in and I was something came up
where he was like yeah it's pretty hard
to get into radio but if you do it's a
lot rewarding and I was like well I kind
of want to get into it he he was like
sorry kid we're not hiding I was like
well I just want to come and like see
the studio can I just come see it he was
like all right why don't you come in
next Tuesday and you can take a look at
how we do the morning show and it's like
a thing and I was like cool so I went in
the next Tuesday and I thought it was
amazing they had like these huge ass
boards they were telling jokes the whole
time there was Dave and shorty and a guy
named Twiggy fat saxs which is a
horrible name but like that really his
that Twiggy yes uh this is none of this
is made up and at the very very end of
their episode they said well we do have
a special guest here today uh some kid
from the the local community college do
you want to come in and say something
and I had like I had to take the extra
mic and I was and I made like I don't
know what joke I made but I said
something that was funny and everyone
kind of laughed and the show ended and I
said that was amazing uh and the guy
said you know why don't you come back
again on Tuesdays and Thursdays every
week you can intern for us and kind of
learn the ropes and I was like I was
like okay once you get your foot in the
door
you can kind of do this so I started
coming in every Tuesday Thursday and
then something happened where they uh
the mid the midafternoon guy or girl had
to go to a different station or moved
out so they had to replace that person
and Twiggy fat saxs took the took the
opportunity so now I get moved into his
position which is the third mik normally
I would have to stand there for the
entire time and if I had a funny joke
that I felt would be ready I'd go like
this and I'd be like joke and then they
take it away that was like really high
sorry Connor that was really high please
take both no but like but then you're
really worried like this joke better be
good because you're you're requesting
like the 19yearold to come in and say
like a funny thing yeah and uh then I
got moved to the third mic which was on
all the time and I was also the phone
guy who I would take like see 95.7 this
is Kramer that was my nickname my call
name was Kramer oh so you were like on
the air while on that one I could hit a
button to mute my my mic too so I'd have
to take the call and they'd say like
yeah I want to tell Dave that I want to
have his babies and you're like okay
that's not thank you very much for
calling you know whatever the Callins
and if it was a good call I'd push it
forward and they would te take it on the
air right yeah so there was one
disturbing Trend that started to to
develop while we were on this morning
show one it was imagine though if you're
like in Melbourne or London and your
voice is heard to like your buddies at
like 18 19 years old this is like a
crazy opportunity right and like my mom
would be listening at her her dentist
office and she'd be like that's my son
Kramer and it was really like pretty
awesome and but they started to really
use me as a punching bag really really
regularly and then it became like I can
take it let's make self you know
self-deprecating humor I can handle that
and then it started getting kind of
offensive so anytime I would say any
kind of joke like they'd be like who's
the loser who like takes baths and I'd
be like I that's the the lead in yeah I
take baths every time I spoke they would
hit this sound bite and this is kind of
offensive I'm sorry to anybody they'd
say you fairy you company man which is a
movie quote from like alpacino right and
it was a derogatory slur to make it
sound like I was not manly or whatever
the joke was and so then it that started
and then each day it got worse with like
making fun of me let's they did a win a
date with Kramer like you know and then
we'd have like the camera crew and they
set it all up and then they had the
camera show there and I showed up to the
thing and they made a big joke saying
nobody signed up for it you're a loser
like and I was like okay and they never
even put it out right so now I'm like
all right what the [__] this is really
bad [__] up it was but this was the
this was like 2003 so I decided I have
some dignity left I I probably should
quit and so I said listen I really
appreciate your guys' opportunity I
learned a lot being on the radio
business this past year I I think it'd
be best if I focused on my studies and
they were like that's good because we
were going to fire you and I was like
okay well then that's that's great all
right so what a bunch of assoles I know
and so but I'm So Young right and I
don't know how to to deal with that
would be stressful to yeah dude it was
crazy so I remember they said here's the
idea that we've got we're going to do a
two-day event where you get made fun of
a lot and we're going to we're going to
pretend that you blow up on the air and
we're going to get suspended for a
weekend so we can go to Vegas to see a
Britney Spears concert and at first I I
I was pretty pressure I was like okay
that sounds good you know this okay
let's just do that and so the first day
we do it I play the part as I knew I
could perfectly I said you guys I've had
enough of every day you're playing these
sound drops or you're making fun of me
or win a date with krer why don't you
win a date with go yourself you know
something like that and it went really
well except I had an email that was like
Kramer
z95.7 for about a year I had like three
emails ever sent to that address and
they were all like uh can you ask out
shorty for me I think she's a babe and
after that episode I had thousands of
emails of people hating me saying that I
didn't appreciate this golden
opportunity to be on the and I was like
it's a joke everybody I thought this was
obvious my mom was concerned she was
like what happened it sounded so real
you act too good I too good so you were
too good too good so I told my acting
coach I was like dude I'm pretty nervous
I was like this is not going well I have
people calling my home phone saying that
I'm ungrateful I don't even know how
they found me I'm not in the phone book
as Kramer you know but like and so I
said he was like yeah dude it's [__]
up it's dumb you know what if I if I was
you I'd go in there tomorrow and I'd be
like [__] you I'm not doing your stupid
gag and you can go [__] yourself yeah
and I was like go in there and say [__]
you and go [__] yourself okay I can do
that no I couldn't I I I so I went there
and I was like all right it's my last
day I'm supposed to do this one last bit
and somehow I did get the courage to to
say no but I've never had such a dry
mouth in my entire must been terrifying
just completely CU you know you
obviously raised your whole life being
like don't talk back or this you
this to me at the time symbolized some
sort of like Gateway or opportunity and
I wanted to to transition to sports
radio and so I was asking for like a
recommendation so I an intern at the the
AM station and I go in there and they go
okay man so we're going to do this thing
and then we're going to uh we're just
going to have you leave but thanks so
much and I was like there's like two or
three minutes before the show starts and
I was
like they were like are you all right
and I was like yeah I was like um
actually I'm not going to go through
with it and they're like you're not
going to go through with what you you
can't work here anymore and I was like
no I think this I think that I think
that this this joke is stupid and I
don't want to do it and they were like
I'm actually getting nervous now
remembering and like and but they were
like they the girl tore into me and she
was she was really really ruthless she
was like honestly you've never had an
ounce of talent for this profession and
we only kept you until we found someone
better and I was like that's fine I'm
not doing this stupid joke
and she was like you will never ever
work in this town again and I was
like that's
fine I was like oh that's not good I
kind of live here I'm very young and I
was like that's fine you know and then I
was like it's not worth it because I I
just don't understand why can't you guys
say we were just joking thank you so
much Peter for your hard work good luck
at the University why can't we have like
a a nice thing and they were like and I
saw da he took the the volume control
and he's like we just can't trust you
today and he's I was like [__] you you
know I was like what a loser and I was
feeling really down and they uh they
told me to go sit in the uh corner and
they went live like I was like some bad
kid or something and I was sitting there
and um they had to go to commercial
break and they were kind of just doing
the show as normal and someone called in
and they they put him on but not on air
it was just 5.7 what and it was my
teacher he didn't know I was there and
he was like yeah
you guys are [__] lame asses and I
think all of you especially you Dave you
[__] hack you're a bunch of losers
and for you to take advantage of that
young man who gave you a year of your
time you know you can go [__] yourself
and that moment I felt like somebody had
in my back this is like a film I know
dud it was crazy and like and he was
they're like you know we're not going to
put he's like I don't want to be on the
[__] air I have some dignity I don't
want to be on z95 point [__] off and I
was like damn so when when that guy was
going hard and then I I I was just like
[__] it I'm out my left and I just
walked out and like it ended and I
thought for sure well that's it that's
acting reron Ronis but I felt um after
that I felt like embracing failure was
actually more of an important lesson to
learn than it is to earn people's like
Ovation and like oh totally so by
embracing failure I maybe should have
overcorrected and not embraced that much
because for the next four or five years
I put myself in any possible acting
situation good or bad so that I not like
porn but like say not like porn but like
any kind of opportunity to to to grow as
a as an actor and stuff like that and I
had a lot of fun doing that but that one
thing changed everything when I when I
got did you never work in that City
again I actually did work in that City
again bastards and uh and I went on on
to um yeah you always yeah you always
recount the story about how you um won
this quite significant acting I did I
got to perform in the Kennedy Center on
uh in Washington DC and so awesome there
was
a this is actually kind of awkward as
well but I'll tell it so uh there was a
well no no it's a cool story but like
there was a there was a contest called
the Irene Kennedy Casey Kennedy C
Kennedy Center American acting theater
Festival what what age is this around
this is all college oh it's the entire
United States and I would argue it's
probably the most prestigious
competition that you can do in college
and no one from our school both my
community college and my college had
ever won it we never we gotten runner up
a couple of times and R up for a whole
country for the region so there's five
different regions and we represented the
kind of the Midwest region which
included Wisconsin Chicago Illinois oh
so you
were so you are the representative for
the Midwest is what I'm was like a
competition as well to get to that point
so yes so I'm not explaining this like
an anime tournament yeah this is like a
sports this is like a Sports Anime we
got to win regionals ma we can do it let
me let me so let me scale it back so if
you're in a show a college show you'll
have an adjudicator come watch it and
the director chooses one actor and the
adjudicator chooses one actor to then go
on to this Regional festival and I was
selected for five years in a row cuz I'm
wow took and I lost every single time
the first four years so what what did
you have to do so you go there and you
have to do a two-minute scene with a
partner um that's it can be self-written
it can be from a famous play it could be
whatever it could be a musical it could
be Shakespeare whatever you want it's
actually three minutes the first round
is 3 minutes if you make it to
semi-finals they take like eight five or
600 different pairs and then they narrow
it down to 32 or 64 and then you do
another two-minute piece so you do a 3
minute and a 2-minute and then if you
make it to the finals you add a one
minute monologue right so on my fifth
year I was like okay this is getting
embarrassing I've been nominated a lot
oh you never got to the finals I made it
to semis once I see and and at the
school at that time a lot of people
looked up to me as an actor because I
took it really seriously I may not have
been the most naturally gifted but I
would really you put I put the work so I
think a lot of people really had high
expectations right so I decided that for
the final year I got this amazing
partner named cie and she's such a great
actress but she was really young she was
like 19 or 20 and I was like 23 at the
time right and so you're asking someone
really new to theater to take some big
risks as we do these scenes so the first
scene was really easy It's the funniest
piece of literature I've ever performed
in and it was written by my old acting
coach so it's this guy meets this girl
and story as old as time but the whole
point is for the first minute and a half
2 minutes their inner monologue is
talking instead of them directly so he's
saying oh my God it's her and then she
says it's him and It All Leads up to
their initial awkward conversation easy
clear made it to simmies we knew we were
going to make it to simmies this scene
was perfect right the problem was it was
so funny that we didn't have a
contrasting piece strong enough so I
talked to this old wizen like Jedi
acting coach and I was like I just don't
trust this second piece that we have and
she goes I have just this scene for you
but you have 20 20 hours to get it into
shape and I was like all right and she's
like it just came out so I know the
playright personally I'll email him and
ask him if we can get permission to use
his works and I was like okay this was a
really interesting play called red light
winner and it's extremely graphic and
the problem with this scene was the
character I played starts with him with
a girl downstage looking up at him
saying I love you and he says you've
never loved me or something like this
yeah yeah and they have this brief
tussle of intense emotional connection
of making
out this is in front of an audience and
then he takes her behind a table not so
different than this lifts up her shirt
and U spits in his hand and drops his
any
well dogs yeah and then yes that's
actually kind of key um then while while
this is happening right this thing his
phone goes off and he covers her mouth
and he takes the call and it's from his
wife saying that he'll be home later and
then the real acting the tough part is
is the girl has to take this information
this betrayal and visualize it for
everybody to see plus all the risque
stuff we're doing yeah he hangs up the
phone finishes whatever that task was
looks at her as he's belt you know and
he says I told you I didn't love you and
that's the end of the scene big contrast
huge contrast Whiplash for the the
audience but but a great way to show R
he was down bad down bad down
baded down you have to be bricked up for
this bricked up down bad all these terms
come full circle and uh the the the key
part of that scene actually is she does
have HIV and now he in turn will get it
so that's not displayed in that
particular scene so then we did we made
it to finals so now it's down to the
final 16 people in our region and this
is like we're in Uncharted Territory can
we be one of the two winners to ever
make it out of this region and go to
Washington mest well for our school yeah
the entire Midwest and so cuz two people
go from each region and uh it was like
okay this is it and we drew numbers on
which order we got to go in and I drew
15 out of 16 which I loved I was like
you get to watch I don't watch anything
but I want to be near the end because I
know that those scenes that we do are so
powerful it leaves an impact very much
and the monologue so we go to the we
start the thing and I actually was so
confident that I slept for about 40
minutes during the first round so I was
just like calm down rest and my partner
poor Cali was just sweating sweating and
terrified so I'll never forget it though
man we we went out there and it was in
Kansas actually the regional that year
it was in KU so it it's my own backyard
I had a chance to defend home turf we
walk out there and there's 2,000 people
in the auditorium and they're all
they've heard rumors of some of the I
heard about this scene so it gets dead
silent and that's already extremely
exciting so you're like everyone's
anticipated oh man it was so you could
feel the place just ready to go so I was
terrified you know but you got to own it
so I said hello my name is Peter this is
my partner cot we'll be doing three
pieces for you today and inside I'm just
I'm all bricked
[Music]
up you're
emotionally in the finals you to perform
three scenes we have to do the the the
com a six minute and it's ruthlessly
timed if you go over time somebody will
put their hand up at 15 seconds and then
they'll stand up and say finish and if
you go over time you're disqualified oh
[__] so this is where thank you for it's
like you're helping me tell this story
well I'm trying to visualize so I can
get my the head head that be awkward if
they shall finish like the second scene
I presume that's to make sure obiously
if you were to finish finish obviously
obviously timing is a huge part of
acting and and being on Queue and on
time is important so I'm guessing that's
why right there was one problem though
we didn't realize was the the comedic
scene was so funny with 2,000 people we
had to pause for laughter so that did so
I think they actually give you a
10-second grace period so like you know
whatever they whatever but so like we do
the first scene it kills people are
going crazy with laughter people there's
already like tons of cheering and then
we got to put that behind us and we have
to do that really serious scene yo my
god dude when that the whip dude you
could not hear anything during that
scene dead silent one guy in the back
was like you know and it was just it was
dead I had like friends and family
watching and they didn't know I was
going to do this scene where I'm like
and it's just but it's fine because it's
it's theater so and then we did a
monologue and I know that Cali went off
stage and I had to do a it was a really
great place uh play called um recent
tragic events about 911 and uh it was a
great monologue it was you did a KNE
it's a good play though it's a it's a
really powerful play American thing I've
ever it was really it was still
relatively topical back it's like within
10 years of this well you said 2003
right this no this was this was five
years of me doing it this must have been
2008 or n or something like that yeah
still so and that play I played the
neighbor of someone as we were're at an
apartment we're watching the the events
unfold and her sister happens to be in
the tower or was she okay and it's just
like a two-hour look into that moment of
time yeah but this character was really
funny very quirky it towed the line
between serious and comedic right and I
and I remember I was kind of kneeling
down telling this this end of the story
and I saw the person stand up and I was
like we're out of time but I still took
that one extra second I'll never forget
it my entire life I stood up and I got
to see the entire audience and it looked
like some weird watercoloring because it
was just all these images and faces and
when I got to say before I could finish
the words thank you the place went
ballistic just insane
clapping theater programs being it was
like some sort of ridiculous thing yeah
and whether I knew if I won or lost it
was irrelevant I felt so satisfied after
all these years of training that we had
a moment that meant something to someone
else which is the whole point of theater
and so it was pretty exciting and then
when we found out they uh we ended up
winning first place on that competition
we got to go to the Kennedy Center we
got to perform on the stage and I got a
nice cash prize for best comedic scene a
um there was the one that we had written
you know and that money went straight to
me coming to Japan oh hell yeah did you
end up winning in uh uh we did not get
the first place tragically this is
actually point of contention this is
really embarrassing it is pretty I mean
I don't hold them accountable but it's
really embarrassing that this happened
during our second scene where the phone
goes off we had rigged it already so
that someone would call the stage
manager for the Kennedy Center who's not
actually doing anything they were just
watching yeah their phone went off
during our scene like like a and so I
think I reached for the phone before the
moment and like and it it cie kind of
rushed well she didn't do anything wrong
but like she moved on to what I was
doing and then we kind of like corrected
it and then it was like wait that wasn't
and then I phone went off when it was
supposed to and you're like and as a
stage manager kind of like you really
should have had that on you're the last
guy on Earth you really should not have
that on but you're [__] up yep so um
other than that you know I took those
things that I learned and I taught drama
in high schools here I've I've been in
some various funny different comedic
things for Japanese media working for
NHK similar to you did BBC so it's
always been a through line of like my my
life and my career was doing theater all
from those radio bastards who told me I
was was the origin story often often a
[__] experience is a bigger motivator
than a good one I find y there you go
for sure your life is an anime yeah it's
crazy we're just going through all like
the cannon events in your life I do have
one the we one brief one that sucked
really bad when I told you failure it's
a quick one I there was ESPN is a pretty
big Sports Network you told me this
story dumb and I was like it was right
after I'd been fired from the radio
station and I told I was they came to
our town to to interview anybody who it
was the first like reality TV show
during like Survivor season 1 was still
on you know and it was dream job where
you could win a a job as a host for
sports center for a year and I was like
dude that's so sick and my my acting
coach was like yeah go and [__] do it
what are they going to do z95.7 you and
I was like yeah you're right I can go
and do it so I wore like my nicest suit
and I I always looked kind of wild
anyway with my messy hair and like I
always stuck out in a way so we're we're
in line for there's like 300 people and
they have this camera crew coming along
and they they stopped at me and they
said hey you look pretty interesting
What's your deal and I was like oh I'm a
I'm a theater student at the University
and they're like oh whoa we got any
theater you can show us and I was like
never say no never say no don't be
afraid of failure and I was like yeah I
do but it's not it's a it's a really uh
well it's a um it's a serious piece like
go ahead and show it it was like really
serious it was like my dad like abused
me and now
like and so this is a sport
center I was like but I I I did the
monologue as best as I could and I
remember uh I remember one of the lines
in the the the monologue is is what the
hell do you think you're doing is one of
the lines yeah and I remember it was a
camera like that with like this enormous
camera and I could as I'm doing the
monologue I see like the cameraman look
like should we just cut this guy what's
going and I you know worst mod I was
like what the hell do you think you're
doing and and they were like dead silent
not the eruption that we got years later
and uh they they were like thank you so
much for your your monologue that was
really good good luck inside I was like
thank you and then the guy next to me I
was like that did not feel good he was
like it's not good better you than me
and I was like okay and then I I was
like I didn't get invited to Bristol
Connecticut I did not get invited to be
a part of sports center so I felt like
okay at at least I can live with the
fact that I tried I turn on the the
first episode and they're like welcome
to ESPN you know dream job thousands
applied and it shows all these people
who are being and they said let's take a
look at the people who didn't make the
cut and I was like please don't do that
please don't do this and it has like all
these different people and then one
person does like a shitty job and then
right after it it zooms in on my fat
face going what the hell do you think
you're doing and then I was and then I
got like 10 phone calls I oh you want
Sports and I was like oh my God so
somewhere out there in some dark dank
closet there's a there's a tape of me a
full video of that horrible mon never
get it lost media lost media thank God
but yeah that's that's when you take
willing to fail too far at least when
you were a you didn't do
the
can I use you for like one second and
then my dad abused me while auditioning
for Sports Center was not the play I
imagine I could I should have just
improvised anything other than that that
was that was a risky move you know let's
see if it PS out you live and learn so
but these stories in the moment they
felt [__] horrible but when you look
back on them now you great story Lear
learning experience and great to accept
your the Dumber aspects of one's life I
think satisfy stories about absolutely
it's completely all right yep holy [__]
some wins and some losses I yeah I I
booked McDonald's a long time that was
just one big loss I didn't even get a
that job that's right you applied and
you got turned down by McDonald's and my
dad thought I was going to be unemployed
for the rest of my life and here you are
and he he's kind of right yeah he's kind
of especially right same nailed failed
it y but uh yeah thanks for coming out
Pete for two hours all right yeah yeah
thanks for coming out Pete hon always
great having you always a pleasure thank
you so much thank you for gracing us
again with your many stories Godlike
stories and uh now we know you are
definitely one of us with your very bad
opinions on [__] and you know what
happened to Har Bay now I learned a lot
today hey look at all these patrons
though amazing wow that's my favorite
right there good one that's a choice con
2012 I'm joking you can cut that one you
can cut that we'll keep it in there's a
lot there someone is going to change
their name to that hey if you like to
support the show then go up to our
patreon patreon.com trast also follow us
on Twitter send us memes on the subeddit
if you had a face listen to us on
Spotify and of course go check out
Pete's stuff links in the description
why don't have to tell you to do that go
do that right now go check out his
streams now yeah there's also uh you're
on YouTube now you loaded more on
YouTube go check it out thank you so
much guys yeah hell yeah all right we'll
see you guys next week
[Music]
bye that was a fun one hell yeah yeah
hell yeah
always